I've been working in music,
I've been playing since I was a kid.
Uh,
but in the industry itself,
the first record I ever played on that
was a major record was Lauren Hill's
album,
the miseducation of Lauryn Hill back in
1998.
I was still in college at University of
Pennsylvania.
I had a friend who was a friend of
Lawrence and she introduced me to her.
This was after the success of the score
by the foods eat.
And so lauren was a big star and
everyone was anticipating or solo album.
And uh,
I went to the studio with them one day
and just hung out.
And,
uh,
she,
heard me saying,
I played a couple songs for her and she
thought it sounded good and wanted me to
play piano on the track she was working
on.
So I did it.
I played on it and,
uh,
she liked what I did and,
she kept it on the album.
Song was called everything is
everything,
which was a pretty big hit back in 98,
99.
And,
uh,
I was just really proud to be a part of
such an important album and that was my
first entry into the big time,
the big leagues,
uh,
of the music business.
But it was just a session.
I just play the piano.
And that was that.
Um,
as I progressed as a writer and as a
singer,
I worked with different producers,
some in Philly.
So I'm in New York and,
uh,
I put a couple of different variations
of my band together and I just kept
trying to get a record deal.
Uh,
I would play at local clubs in New York
and Philadelphia,
sometimes Atlanta,
sometimes DC,
just trying to get some buzz and
building an audience.
And it kept building and building.
Uh,
a couple of years into me living in New
York,
I met Kanye West,
who at the time was still an unknown
producer from Chicago who had just moved
out to the east coast.
He was the,
uh,
he is the cousin of a,
one of my good friends,
Devonne Harris,
who is also a producer and one of my
classmates from college.
And,
uh,
we started working together,
Kanye and I,
and I think that was the biggest,
uh,
different maker in my career.
Uh,
when I started working with him,
his star was just starting to ascend
and,
uh,
I kind of hitched on to that and,
his ascension really helped me get
noticed by the right people and we made
some really cool music together.
Him and I,
uh,
on his project and,
also,
uh,
on my own project and other people's
projects like slum village,
Alicia keys,
Jay z,
all these things were happening before I
got a record deal and they were helping
me get the buzz and the energy around my
project that I needed to get a record
deal.
And finally,
in 2004,
I signed with Sony through Connie's
imprint and I released my first album
get lifted in December of 2014.
It really hasn't changed a lot.
Uh,
we were never close friends.
in the beginning it was more of a
professional relationship that developed
into a friendship.
And we're still friends and we still,
you know,
joke around in the same way we did
before.
We still work together in a similar way
that we did before.
And I think we still have a respect for
each other's creativity,
uh,
that we did before.
And,
uh,
I,
I believe Kanye is one of the most
important creative minds and music right
now.
And I'm excited to still be able to
work.